Isn't it frustrating
when you're watching TV series or movie
or you're listening to a song
and you can't understand what was said?
Usually this is not
because the person is speaking too fast.
Rather, it is
because you are not used to how natives
reduce, cut
and connect our words together.
However, you can learn it
so that you can understand natives
no matter how fast we speak.
And the most fun way to do this
is with our Fluent With Friends course.
In this course,
you will learn all of the most common
aspects of connected speech so that
you can confidently understand natives
and even improve your pronunciation.
So you can give it a try now for free
with our 3-part master class.
What are you waiting for?
Just click up here
or down in the description below to sign up now.
Want to improve your English speaking?
Then check out this lesson where you can
practice your speaking with Cassé.
Let's check it out. Here you go.